hello everyone so in this video I'm
gonna introduce vector fields now these
are concepts that come up all the time
in multivariable calculus and that's
probably because they come up all the
time in physics you know it comes up
with fluid flow with electrodynamics you
see them all over the place and what a
vector field is is it's pretty much a
way of visualizing functions that have
the same number of dimensions in their
input as in their output so here I'm
going to write a function that's got a
two dimensional input X and y and then
this output is going to be a two
dimensional vector and each of the
components will somehow depend on x and
y I'll make the first one Y cubed minus
9y and then the second component the Y
component of the output will be X cubed
minus 9x
I made them symmetric here looking kind
of similar they don't have to be I'm
just kind of a sucker for symmetry so if
you imagine trying to visualize a
function like this with I don't know
like a graph it would be really hard
because you have two dimensions in the
input two dimensions in the output so
you'd have to somehow visualize this
thing in four dimensions so instead what
we do we look only in the input space so
that means we look only in the XY plane
so I'll draw these coordinate axes and
just mark it up this here is our x-axis
this here is our y-axis and for each
individual input point like let's say
1/2 so let's say we go to 1/2 I'm going
to consider the vector that it outputs
and attach that vector to the point so
let's let's walk through an example of
what I mean by that so if we actually
evaluate F at 1/2 X is equal to 1 Y is
equal to 2 so we plug in 2 cubed whoops
2 cubed minus 9 times 2 up here in the X
component and then 1 cubed minus 9 times
y 9 times 1 excuse me
down in the Y component 2 cubed is 8 9
times 2 is 18 so 8 minus 18 is negative
10 negative 10 and then 1 cubed is 1 9
times 1 is 9 so
1 minus 9 is negative 8 now first
imagine that this was if we just drew
this vector where we count starting from
the origin negative 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
so he's gonna have this as its
x-component and the negative 8 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 we're gonna actually go off the
screen it's a very very large vector so
it's gonna be something here and it ends
up having to go off the screen but the
nice thing about vectors it doesn't
matter where they start so instead we
can start it here and we still want it
to have that negative 10 X component in
the negative 8 so when I go to 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 negative 8 as its Y component
there so this is a really big vector and
a plan with the vector field is to do
this at not just 1 2 but at a whole
bunch of different points and see what
vector is attached to them and if we
drew them all according to their size
this would be a real mess there'd be
markings all over the place and you'd
have you know this one might have some
huge vector attached to it and this one
would have some huge vector attached to
it and it would get really really messy
but instead what we do so I'm gonna just
clear up the board here we scaled them
down this is common you'll scare them
down so that you're kind of lying about
what the vectors themselves are but you
get a much better feel for what each
thing corresponds to and another thing
about this drawing that's not entirely
faithful to the original function that
we have is that all of these vectors are
the same length you know I made this one
I'm just kind of the same unit this one
the same unit and over here they all
just have the same length even though in
reality the length of the vectors output
by this function can be wildly different
this is kind of common practice when
vector fields are drawn or when some
kind of software is drawing them for you
so there are ways of getting around them
this one way is to just use colors with
your vector so I'll switch over to a
different vector field here and here
color is used to kind of give a hint of
length so it still looks organized
because all of them have the same same
length but the difference is
red and warmer colors are supposed to
indicate this is a very long vector
somehow and then blue would indicate
that it's very short another thing you
can do is scale them to be roughly
proportional to what they should be so
notice all the blue vectors scaled way
down to basically be zero red vectors
kind of stayed the same size and even
though in reality this might be
representing a function where the true
vector here should be really long or the
true vector here should be got a medium
length it's still common for people to
just shrink them down so it's a
reasonable thing to view so in the next
video I'm gonna talk about fluid flow a
context in which vector fields come up
all the time and it's also a pretty good
way to get a feel for a random vector
field that you look at to understand
what it's all about